[Musik]
das ist kreuzgefährlich finde ich was da
los läuft wäre schon schön haben sich
die gemüter wieder beruhigen würden aber
angst das ist vielleicht noch nachher
zum abwurf einer atombombe kommen das
ist auf jeden fall eine sehr bedrohliche
situation wenn einige kommen würde wäre
problematisch so viele deutsche und das
irgendwie kein gas mehr da ist dass wir
frieren ich weiß nicht was das dann für
europa bedeutet da sind wir nicht so
weit weg wenn irgendwas passieren sollte
ja das sind stimmen die ein gefühl
beschreiben ein gefühl das uns beinahe
acht jahrzehnte lang nicht mehr so
ernsthaft im griff hatte wie in diesen
tagen die angst vor einem neuen krieg in
europa wie nah steht der kontinent vor
einer militärischen konfrontation
zwischen russland und der ukraine
und was kann deutschland beitragen ein
solches blutvergießen zu verhindern
das wollen wir ausloten in diesem zdf
spezial herzlich willkommen dazu ja der
kanzler heute in kiel von gleich morgen
in moskau regierungschefs und
außenminister vieler länder im
krisenmodus diplomatie in dauerschleife
aber bislang ohne erkennbare erfolge der
russische truppenaufmarsch jedenfalls
geht unvermindert weiter begleitet von
immer lauter werdenden warnungen aus
washington
russische übungen nahe der ukrainischen
grenze
schon morgen könne ein vorgetäuschter
russische angriff auf das eigene
staatsgebiet einen vorwand für den
einmarsch geben so heißt es aus
geheimdienstkreisen
die us regierung warnt immer wieder
wir können nicht genau den tag voraus
sagen aber wir sind im zeitfenster eine
invasion eine große militärische aktion
durch russland in der ukraine könnte
jederzeit beginnen auch diese woche vor
dem ende der olympischen spiele
was dann die usa werden auf keinen fall
eigene soldaten in die ukraine schicken
betont präsident biden mit starker
rhetorik
wann würden sie truppen senden um us
bürger aus der ukraine zu retten gar
nicht das wäre ein weltkrieg wenn
amerikanische und russische soldaten
aufeinander schießen dann wäre die welt
eine andere
im telefonat mit präsident putin von joe
biden noch mal ein klares bekenntnis zur
diplomatie kompromisse ja
sicherheitsgarantien nein die us
reaktion getragen von drei säulen
stärkung der nato ostflanke zusätzliche
3000 us soldaten sollen nach polen
reisen sofortige sanktionen im fall
eines russischen einmarsch und die
weitere versorgung der ukraine mit
waffen
ungewöhnlich offen die kommunikation
veröffentlichung von truppenbewegungen
von geheimdiensterkenntnissen wozu
wir wissen jetzt so viel mehr über die
russische desinformations maschine als
bei der invasion in die ukraine 2014 und
wir haben eine strategische entscheidung
getroffen es des information zu nennen
wenn wir es sehen und wir müssen der
welt und der us öffentlichkeit sehr klar
sagen was sie versuchen zu tun und warum
und trotzdem noch die leiser werdende
hoffnung dass der konflikt diplomatisch
gelöst werden kann
und den berlin begrüße ich den kurs chef
der grünen und außen politiker omid
nouripour guten abend gute nacht
nouripour leben glauben sie in diesen
tagen mehr den amerikanern und ihren
warnungen vor einer russischen invasion
oder den russen die solche pläne
abstreiten es ist eine sehr bedrohliche
situation der zeit dass die russen so
viele kräfte dort hoch bewaffnet und
gefechts bereich passiert haben deutet
auf nichts gutes an es ist auch
traditionell so dass demokratische
kräfte er einander vertrauen auf
vertrauen sollten deshalb glaube ich
eher den amerikanern aber wir hoffen
natürlich dass diese sehr sehr enge
prophezeiung eines schnellen krieges
nicht kommt und deshalb bin ich auch
froh dass die aussenministerinnen der
bundeskanzler unterwegs sind um einen
krieg auch etwas entgegenzusetzen
nämlich eine beherzte diplomatie beide
sichern der ukraine jetzt volle
solidarität zu können sie nachvollziehen
dass vielen ukrainern das nicht reicht
und wahrscheinlich auch nicht hilft im
konflikt mit russland
nach meinem eindruck ist dass in der
ukraine klar dass wir auf ihrer seite
stehen ich habe ja sehr viele freunde
und auch beziehungen in das land hinein
es ist schon so dass innerhalb der
ukrainischen innenpolitik sowie in der
deutschen auch in der amerikanischen
auch immer wieder forderungen gestellt
werden die nicht einhellig geteilt
werden aber wir als das land das auch in
den letzten acht jahren seit der
annexion ergrimmt die meisten
finanziellen unterstützungen auch auf
den tisch gelegt hat für die ukraine die
wir beim staatsaufbau bei der frage
korruptionsbekämpfung und vielen stellen
stets an der seite der ukraine gestanden
haben und eine tiefe
sicherheitskooperation haben mit dem
land wir sind an ihrer seite und viele
ukraine wissen dass diese botschaft hat
olaf scholz ja heute auch in kiew
hinterlassen morgen reist er nach moskau
weiter was muss der kanzler erreichen um
die lage spürbar zu deeskalieren
es muss sehr klar und deutlich
russischen seite übermittelt werden dass
wir weiterhin gesprächsbereit sind das
die dritte diplomatie nicht umsonst
glühen aber das muss dann auch wissen
muss dass eine weitere aggression
richtung ukraine einen hohen preis hat
und dass für den fall aller
sanktionsmechanismen auch auf dem tisch
sind das ist auch ein herrlich in dieser
regierung beschlossen worden und
verabredet worden apropos
sanktionsmechanismen wenn es nicht
gelingen sollte zu deeskalieren ist nord
stream 2 dann geschichte das hier wäre
ihre chance dass zumindest für ihre
partei mal deutlich auszusprechen
das ist offenbar klar dass die grünen
immer schon gegensatz zu ihm waren sowie
die sozialdemokratie immer dafür war der
streit bleibt auch bestehen aber im
falle eines krieges sind alle
instrumente auf dem tisch auch noch zwei
das hat der bundeskanzler auch
beispielsweise auf seiner reise in
madrid gesagt da sehen wir uns einig es
geht hier nicht darum welche partei
welche farbe gut aussieht sondern dass
kein krieg jetzt in europa entflammt und
dafür müssen wir jetzt alles tot mal
sehen inwieweit sich ihre haltung
innerhalb der ampel koalition
tatsächlich durchsetzt omid nouripour
danke für diese auskünfte größter nach
berlin dann gehen
und das gespräch haben wir kurz vor der
sendung aufgezeichnet
lösen sie die schlinge um den hals der
ukraine hat frank walter steinmeier kaum
wiedergewählt ja gestern im russischen
präsidenten putin zugerufen so schaaf ja
so unmissverständlich es wirkte fast wie
ein rollentausch zwischen dem
bundespräsidenten und dem bundeskanzler
olaf scholz hält sich mit derart harten
ansagen in moskau weiter zu wie manche
glauben auch deshalb weil er seine
mögliche rolle als vermittler nicht
gefährden will seit jahren bemüht sich
berlin darum gemeinsam mit paris den
gewaltsamen konflikt im donbass zu
beenden ein rückblick
die krise beginnt als der ukrainische
präsident janukowitsch auf druck des
kremls ein fast fertiges
assoziierungsabkommen mit der eu auf eis
legt und sich russland zuwendet
hunderttausende gehen daraufhin auf die
straße vor allem auf dem majdan in kiew
die lage eskaliert mehr als 100 menschen
sterben bei straßenkämpfen präsident
janukowitsch flieht nach russland der
konflikt verlagert sich auf die
halbinsel krim zu mehr als der hälfte
von russen gewohnt separatisten besetzen
das parlament in der hauptstadt
simferopol
kiew wirft dem kreml die bewaffnete
invasion der krim vor in einem
umstrittenen referendum stimmen die krim
bewohner über einen beitritt zu russland
ab offiziell sprechen sich mehr als 95
prozent dafür aus die eu und die usa
verhängen darauf sanktionen gegen
russland doch dort herrscht erstmal
volksfeststimmung
die krippen ist heimgekehrt
auf der krim besetzen separatisten
gewaltsam ukrainische verwaltungsgebäude
rufen unabhängige volksrepublik 'nen aus
in kiew wird unterdessen der milliardär
poroschenko neuer präsident er will den
eu beitritt russland droht jetzt mit
ernsten konsequenzen
eine boeing von malaysia airlines stürzt
über der ost ukraine ab 298 menschen
sterben internationale ermittler sind
überzeugt m h 17 wurde von einer
russischen rakete der separatisten
getroffen der westen verschärft seine
sanktionen gegen russland doch das töten
in der ost ukraine geht weiter
bei friedensverhandlungen im sogenannten
normandie format in minsk wollen
deutschland und frankreich vermitteln
mühevoll vereinbart wird eine waffenruhe
die nicht standhält
politikneuling bolelli mirza lenski wird
neuer präsident der ukraine
er kündigt friedensgespräche mit
russland an doch auch er kann an der
situation nichts ändern bis heute hat
der konflikt 13.000 tote gefordert
seit mitte vergangenen jahres zieht
russland immer mehr truppen zusammen
mittlerweile ist die ukraine von fast
130.000 russischen soldaten eingekreist
militärübungen laufen direkt vor der
grenze
ja wie ist die bedrohungslage
einzuschätzen nachfragen dazu an die
frühere nato strategen stefan die basis
zur guten haben nach berlin guten abend
frau waren heute drei stunden lang neben
auswärtigen ausschuss des bundestages zu
gast was haben sie den abgeordneten
gesagt so wie groß ist die akute
kriegsgefahr aus ihrer sicht
ich habe ihnen gesagt dass wir es in der
tat mit einer fundamentalen
sicherheitskrise in europa zu tun haben
dass die militärische eskalation
initiative bei präsident putin liegt er
kann das timing bestimmen die art und
größe einer möglichen operation aber er
kann auch entscheiden nichts zu tun und
an den verhandlungstisch zu kommen und
über die neuordnung der europäischen
sicherheitsarchitektur mit dem westen zu
reden über putins absichten weiß man
wenig schauen wir mal auf die westliche
seite sie selbst waren jahrelang im
nato-hauptquartier in brüssel tätig
haben dort einen strategischen
planungsstab geleitet ist das bündnis
überhaupt vorbereitet auf diese
gegenwärtige eskalation
militärisch ganz sicherlich die nato hat
ja sehr schnell und rasch ihr
militärisches abschreckungs und
verteidigungs dispositiv an der
ostflanke und an der südostflanke
verstärkt und wenn morgen die
verteidigungsminister tagen werden sie
das sicherlich noch einmal
unterstreichen und noch weiter
investieren politisch scheint es mir
eher so zu sein dass die nato ein wenig
überrascht war dass präsident putin zwei
dinge miteinander verknüpft hat die
bildung einer veritablen militärische
drohkulisse und einen ganzen
forderungskatalog die in einer flotten
und brüssel geschickt hat die nato ist
überrascht sagen sie aber einige länder
liefern jetzt auch waffen nachgewiesen
erhöht das eigentlich die militärische
widerstand kauf der ukraine gegen doch
eine hochgerüstete russische armee macht
das einen unterschied am ende
ich fürchte nicht die ukrainischen
streitkräfte haben zwar fortschritte
gemacht sie haben sich modernisiert sie
haben ihre interoperabilität und andere
dinge verbessert auch ihre ausrüstung
viele verbündete auch die vereinigten
staaten haben in den letzten jahren
massiv mit daran gearbeitet die
ukrainischen streitkräfte zu
modernisieren ich glaube die usa haben
2,5 milliarden us dollar alleine an
militärischer ausrüstung und an
ausbildung mit in die schiene investiert
aber unterm strich bleiben auf
ukrainischer seite nicht geringe
defizite in militärischen fähigkeit
bereichen das gilt beispielsweise im
maritimen bereich genauso wie in der
luftverteidigung also kurzum was auch
immer jetzt geschickt wird vielleicht
mit ausnahme von kampfjets und
boden-luft-raketen
würde die den kampf gegen er zwischen
david und goliath nicht wirklich nicht
wirklich verändern letzte frage mit der
bitte um eine kurze antwort ist ein
nato-beitritt der ukraine den sicher das
land wünsch präsident zielinski hat das
heute noch mal bekräftigt tatsächlich
noch eine realistische option angesichts
der russischen reaktion
die nato erweiterung ist ja kein
selbstzweck sondern die nato nimmt nur
neue mitglieder auf wenn sie erstens die
gesamt sicherheit des bündnisses und
aller mitglieder verstärken und zweitens
wenn sie keine wirklichen konflikte auf
ihrem territorium hat und drittens wenn
es den konsens aller 30
bündnismitglieder gibt und diese
voraussetzung sehe ich jetzt und in
nächster zukunft nicht gegeben also
halte ich es für unrealistisch und so
sieht das offenbar auch der
bundeskanzler der heute in kiew sagt ein
nato beitritt stehe zurzeit nicht auf
der tagesordnung danke für diese
auskünfte nach berliner gerne
hätte ein heißer krieg in europa die
frage beantworten zu wollen gleich den
blick in die glaskugel nur soviel egal
wie weit sich die eskalationsspirale am
ende dreht ein neuer kalter krieg ist
doch längst wirklichkeit geworden diese
bittere ernte hat der gegenwärtige
konflikt bereits eingefahren und das ist
eine niederlage für die menschen in
europa in ost wie in west das war unser
zdf spezial danke für ihr interesse und
hier im programm folgt wieso auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]